vous laisser la porte ouverte pendant
longtemps est ce que rappelait à bah
ouais mais on peut carrément pas ouvrir
la porte parce que avec la différence de
pression s arrachent reste c'est quand
même assez violence comme dans un avion
en altitude dont 100 fois pire donc
ouais même un petit trou comme ça si tu
le laisses assez longtemps après t'as
plus d'air c'est ça qui est un peu
difficile en station ça nous arrivait en
avoir un petit trou où la station est un
peu la panique mais une urgence on a des
procédures d'urgence pour ça donc on
fait gaffe pas trop dans la station
c'est comme dans un sous marin comme
dans un bateau ou pire pas de trou dans
la coque interdite